only et caught up with Tyrese Gibson
outside the Det Awards Sunday he talked
to Kevin Frazier about tributes and gave
some exclusive scoop first of all the
Prince tribute how was it listen man I'm
sure everybody is know has was move on
on TV but energy in the room was
something else I still can't believe it
I put up so many rest in peace and gone
too soon
it's like these last five to seven years
have been rough thinking of losses you
guys are shooting fast and furious you
know I know Paul's always in your heart
when you're on set will you pay tribute
to him in some way during this movie you
know I can't really speak on that but I
will say this it it's not easy
moving forward without him and so we
feel there's energy every day this
trailer used to be parked next to mine
so every time I step out of my trail
that's always rough there will be some
real energy and some presents folk but I
just can't go into what that is by the
way a lot of people talk about fast and
furious but nobody's talking about
another movie you're doing right now too
which is kind of amazing doing
transformers aren't you come on you know
too much there's gonna be a lot of
energy out there the universe
FASS a Transformers 5 another howling I
love you listen exclusive I'm walking
away now